Misión cumplida tras 30 años de arduo
trabajo los países más vulnerables a los
peores efectos del cambio climático
salen de esta con 27 con un fondo para
ayudar a pagar por las pérdidas y daños
que han sufrido y que sufrirán en el
futuro por el impacto de los eventos
meteorológicos más extremos una victoria
para el sur global que en bloque luchó
hasta el último minuto para conseguir
este histórico acuerdo cuyos detalles
quedan por definir durante el año que
queda de aquí a la cop 28 en emiratos
árabes Unidos Antonio Gutiérrez el
secretario general de la ONU sin embargo
Recuerda que aunque son avances el
planeta sigue en una situación de salud
crítica Y es que este plan de
implementación desarme elsake ha
aprobado esta mañana en Egipto no va más
allá del pacto de Glasgow en temas de
mitigaciones decir de reducción de
emisiones durante la cop 26 solo se
incluía al carbón en los planes de
reducción progresiva de su uso y ahora
pese a algunas modificaciones en el
texto sobre una ayuda la transición
justa hacia las energías renovables para
países menos industrializados No hay
ninguna mención a otros combustibles
fósiles algo que se interpreta como un
guiño a la Industria del gas y del
petróleo que tanta presencia tuvo en
esta Cumbre recordemos que para poder
mantener el límite del 1,5 grados para
2100 la ciencia dice que hay que reducir
en un 45% las emisiones de CO2 antes del
2030 es decir en poco más de siete años